por supuesto valentina yo creo que
tenemos que ver la situación en
perspectiva la dictadura de enero ortega
empezó suprimiendo los partidos
políticos y encarando los candidatos
también suprimieron y confiscados los
medios de comunicación independientes en
nicaragua inició quiera tenemos un
periódico impreso también entidad
gremiales como el consejo de la empresa
privada
los los presidentes de este esta cámara
están en la cárcel anularon la autonomía
universitaria y el arrasada el de
capital a 758 ongs es parte de esta
operación en donde la dictadura quiere
anular cualquier tipo de organización de
la sociedad civil e imponer un régimen
entonces solamente prevalezca la versión
del estado en donde no sea posible
organizar de ninguna manera este la
gente entre las organizaciones que han
sido prohibidas
es tan disímiles como la carne a la
lengua la academia de ciencias
la asociación de pediatría y por otro
lado así los colegios
ong es a favor del ambiente
uno asumiría que en materia política el
gobierno haga este tipo de cierres pero
qué argumentos hay para cerrar una arena
por una organización de caridad como
ésta de la orden madre teresa de calcuta
o las que usted ya mencionaba como la
academia nicaragüense de la lengua que
esto fue a principios de junio
los argumentos pasan a través de
adefesio jurídico ellos han creado tan
absurdos como vincular a estas monjas
con proliferación del terrorismo y armas
de destrucción masiva
y finalmente hablamos de un proceso que
viene dictado desde el carné en la
pareja presidencial ha dicho hay que
cerrar hay que descabezar a esta ong y
el pretexto es lo de menos
muchas de estas también dicen que no
tiene los estados financieros
actualizados pero cuando uno habla por
lo responsable de esta ong descubre que
simplemente el gobierno no les recibe
los estados financieros una y otra vez
inventa algún pretexto para tener ahí un
add es un adefesio jurídico para
justificar esto a busito a trofeo en
contra del derecho de los nicaragüenses
organizados